I've been struggling to quit vaping
right so I don't want to vape and so
it's just been so hard and I realized
like I'm an addict yeah you know it's
like dude I will wake up in the middle
of the night and like see if there's
Vape places open and stuff and then some
stay started stay open in 24
hours oh yeah like cigarettes was the
hardest for me I love I oh my gosh I
love smoking yeah I love cigarettes um
but I I just can't I don't want to be
that that Mom like well it became my God
like vaping became my higher power in a
lot of ways like if I have an
uncomfortable thought feeling moment
whatever let me hit this thing yeah and
so I realized oh this is the thing I'm
serving this like yeah whether I want to
have a higher power whatever I want it
to be yeah this is whatever I am serving
this thing I show up when this whenever
the little like Ping goes off inside of
me I show up for this thing that's crazy
um yeah I I my life revolved around
smoking too and it's funny because is um
you start like treating it as like
little treats like I would be tattooing
and I'd be like all right I'll just get
through like two hours and then I get a
treat and then you know get these little
breaks and stuff and then but then
everything like life becomes an
inconvenience for at least for me um
I've never talked about this before by
the way like I feel like um usually when
I talk about like subbing and stuff
you're talking about like drugs and but
cigarettes were the hardest I mean it's
I just I love the ritual of it I love
the smell like like leather jackets with
and cigarettes to me is like so sexy I
just I oh Sam Elliot in The Mask have
you seen him in that no was sha remember
in that movie oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was thinking the other mask yeah
yeah I wish Sam Elliot was in that one
too I like Sam Elliot I mean I don't
like him like I like him but I like him
yeah yeah but um yeah people don't talk
enough about that it's yeah it's so I
mean it just the all of it is I mean I
was like two packs a day whatuh like
till recently Hax Von D huh that's crazy
dude two packs a day you're lucky you
look so lovely still after haven't
smoked that much I know yeah true true
not not not I know I mean like but no
it's a b yeah it's like that's fortunate
you see some people that are just like
yeah some people look like they start to
eventually they they look like the
inhale that they take off a cigarette
they're just like you know like like
their whole just like yeah you know yeah
it's but if I see people doing drugs and
movies just instantly get like sick to
my stomach I'm like I just like the idea
the idea of doing drugs again is like
I'm beyond that but if I see somebody
smoking a cigarette I'm like man like I
still have that in like I can't I I
can't um cheat on that like yeah oh I
stopped at a high dude this is the
saddest story I remember kind of Milling
around a high school to see if some kid
was vaping after school one day when we
were and vaping so not cool like that's
the one that's like I'm like like why
just smoke a cigarette like why would
you it's like so like steampunk like
with your little things dude the
steampunks are the craziest about
they're like putting together assembling
like it's so weird just get a cigarette
and be a
man God I didn't I didn't know that that
was such a loser right
now but I'm okay this might be the
conversation I need that helps me yeah I
just didn't uh yeah but the yeah there's
some they the people they put this they
like crank it and they make their own
Vape or whatever they like add vanilla
seasoning it's like they have a machine
it has a tumble dry setting on it like
what yeah these are the guys that are
doing this is a guy let's play that can
we play that let's see one of these yeah
they're the people that blow the smoke
and they what like there's there's team
comp comp like a guy you don't do any of
that I don't do no this guy's out of his
mind this guy has a 12 Gage
Fai oh my God this guy this guy's wife
is
missing there's no reason to need that
much nicotine unless you did something
bad look at that this guy's a damn motor
in but the craziest ones are the
competitions it's almost like it's one
of those dog shows now it's like the guy
will blow a big smoke ring and then his
wife will like run and jump through it
it's like what is this it just
anyway but it's hard it is it's hard and
I think since I don't have a family or
anything that I constantly need to
address then uh I feel like I probably
wouldn't have quit if I didn't have yeah
I mean when I the minute I got pregnant
like I I got the plus sign I that was
the day I quit no and then uh and then I
started again after I had my son not
right away but like you hiding and doing
it no
no yeah no but I pry awesome that
you were no no I mean I never would post
like I've there's you'll be hard pressed
to find there's very few photos of me
smoking online but yeah um but then when
my son was two CU I had my little
smoking Nook outside um and uh he came
out my son came he he learned how to
open doors you know and he came out was
like Mommy Mommy and he's like what's
that spell and I just felt like such a
loser I was like I can't I can't be that
Mom so I yeah oh I would hate that being
that Dad what's that smell it's like oh
it's cranberry Lime Crush or whatever is
that your flavor ice or whatever yeah
whatever no I prefer um watermelon lemon
and sometimes I'll do watermelon lemon
mango if they don't have the one that I
like but it's like it's sad it's all
pretty sad I think oh I was just like I
would just buy cartons I just buy
cartons cartons you buy a boatload you'd
be out there like on the Ohio River like
flagging down I B cartons and then I
like my big one of my biggest pet peeves
was like when people would ask to like
bum a cigarette why you have a cart well
yeah but I've been Prof like I'm
averaging one every 30 minutes I don't
have a spare like why would you do that
like just go buy your
own that's how it was when I was when I
would do drugs too like I I remember in
the beginning it was like fun party time
you're out with your friends and then
the minute that I realized like oh no
this is mine I would just start doing
drugs by myself oh yeah me too yeah like
that was it like no no sharing cuz
there's so many freeloaders yeah and I
was one of them first of all and I'd
finally gotten some drugs so the last
thing if I'm yeah it's finally time I
get to freeload off myself you know but
yeah I would go home I would get cocaine
I would go home and just do it by myself
and it would be sad yeah oh yeah it was
the saddest man uhuh I don't know why
but yeah people do that but yeah I think
a through a through like going to 12ep
meetings is where I started to build a
relationship with a higher power and
really believe in one before that I just
never had it presented to me in a way
that felt uh I don't know that I that it
that it like messed you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah I think that's important I
think is how you how it comes into your
life too you know a lot of times um yeah
and I just like having high power I like
having an invisible friend that um yeah
I like having an invisible friend yeah
yeah I feel like um I came from the the
school of thought where you know you you
have to be like empowered and um you
know just believe in yourself and all
this the this idea that you do you know
it's kind of almost like self- worship
and um and I think Ina you know they
they do talk about that where it's like
that you know you can't do this on your
own and I think taking that to like the
bigger picture part of it um where it's
not just with addiction that for me I'm
like I've definely surrendered to that
and I don't think there's anything wrong
to you know to humble yourself and be
like I can't I can't do this on my own
and so it's kind of where I where I you
know landed I guess yeah yeah what was
it like when you did you think you
really had an addiction problem what was
that like oh yeah I mean I was like a
big time user drug user Loser yeah Loser
yeah that's
fine no I mean you know I I'm like a
quick learner so it's not like I can't
I'm never casual about anything thing um
so it's like you know what starts off as
innocent and just experimentation turns
into like like my entire existence yeah
wow and I you know that that part of my
personality I've change I've managed to
changeed over the years too like I've
grown up a little bit more you know like
what part of it you mean well because I
think before when I looked at like my
relationships so when I looked at
like just everything has to be an excess
you know and and now I'm like a little
more
balanced